our wrists
not anymore verily
we're going to hear in a
take breaks to see and resort
- historical
and
and yeah
so I believe this will be our house for
the night in Kyoto you're gonna drop off
our bags here and I'm about to enter
these steps
hello Julia hi you hit your head today
just about oh look this is a Japanese
home to the max
sahlan dibs here I don't know how called
dance but all I know is that I like hard
floors and it feels really cool in here
so I'm just laying down have you seen
the entire house yet I saw too many
rooms you give up sticky little feet yes
does that make sense no there's an
upstairs
well there's beds yeah it's not as
Japanese as I thought it would be and
you receiving the baby crib oh come on
well someone's gonna sleep there all
right where you are exploring Kyoto
walking down their Main Street I'm
guessing I smell a lot of pretty things
it's a red bean let me know how it goes
looks crunchy though that's good yeah
red bean let me get more real quick and
I got one of those a red bean all thingy
majiggy it's like perfectly round I'm
gonna do that Oh a mold
yeah geez mmm Bunji bite chewy texture
be feeling nice and warm one of my tip
that's mochi is it the salty mochi or is
it sweetie we're gonna eat it here okay
okay Oh careful it looks really hot okay
little hole piece of bacon got Japanese
bacon oh you got the bacon out the ham I
was thinking about getting the bacon you
got the bacon this is Korean BBQ right
here you are the bed I think that's cute
that was smells curative smells
delicious right oh there and that one of
my I'm taking by real quick
explain what you're going through right
now it's a holiday ham meat pork belly
harness newer yakitori style that's
crazy okay my mom
where are we let the cold in holy [ __ ]
this tree I mean holy smokes this tree
I've been trying out the Custis much
lately so that's the new thing don't
curse
do not curse the bathroom over there
Heisey do use a restroom no okay this
last thing these restroom
I predict you will you need to use
restroom in ten minutes
should you use restroom now I think yes
that we even have you okay in ten
minutes I think let's just actually do
this for real it is 228 final just
okay just got our tickets and these
things are awesome they look like
something from the good old days
it looks like old paint Oh money or
something we're going in I think it's
gorgeous with a head out of the way do
you think you can fill that in minecraft
look at it that's the ultimate minecraft
building it builds its gold force of it
yeah feather tail I think you're right
Isaac
is like a DD that's my child
so we're looking at getting some of
these charms TIFF do you find yourself
to be a superstitious person you know
what I do I'm in denial I say that on
believing that stuff but deep down
inside I really do so what kind of
superstitious thing you're gonna get
today I'm gonna get a good luck charm
for a hustle and for your peridot from
my parents word all right I'm gonna show
oh you know what you want you want bar
to pick it one more time I want to I
want to show this footage to what you're
seven years old Marshall this is 17 year
old Isaac in ten years from now so more
than half the time but I knew what every
time I look over at Bart this is this is
Isaac's on Bart for the 90% of the trip
and why do you want part to carry you so
badly because the woman was Sergeant oh
really you know what our free ride huh
is it it isn't because you want a free
ride because your legs are hurting on
sounds [ __ ] oh yeah oh but the only
thing that I'm worried about is Isaac
doesn't want to use his legs
you're gonna have little weak leg later
on you're not gonna be strong you're not
are you are you changing the subject
are you changing the subject oh this is
great fault footage right here this is
going to the vault when we find out why
it'll make the track team with the
basketball team the soccer team because
you have opinion he legs and we have
evidence right here
I don't mind carrying you well you're
not gonna make any left seven years old
almost eight eight years old eight in
one month over and when I'm alright oh
my god oh really you gave you a warning
that that was coming
are you guys ready for that 24/7 no no
one's earning our [ __ ] you guys do it
like no one's dirty you know what you
know what it is though when you have
your kid you're not gonna see your kick
is your kids [ __ ] jump on us yeah you
have Isaac right now and then we're like
telling it all up roars letting it
happen how are they like remember
I don't adore this you know what what
they have their kids and Isaac is old
enough I do anything their kids are
gonna be the ones go and I think anyone
getting karma car is gonna happen real
so I had nothing against holding you
it's just that you got too big and I'm
weak
Hey and was it cold yesterday it was
warm yesterday was it cold today I'm
giving my gesture I'm good
no no come on hey you can't deny it now
and thank you I love you is the best
thing is pretty Wow though many colors
whoa you got cops issue behind you guys
competition possible
ah sweet
Oh
Oh tired